hi folks I want to bring you up to speed
with something that's happening today
which is that I've developed mild
symptoms of the corona virus that's to
say a temperature and a persistent cough
and on the advice of the chief medical
officer I've taken a test that has come
out positive so I am working from the
home I'm self isolating and that's
entirely the right thing to do but being
no diet that I can continue a thanks to
the wizardry of modern technology to
communicate with all my top team to lead
the national fight back against corona
virus and I want to thank everybody
who's involved I want to thank that of
course above all our amazing NHS staff
it was very moving last night to join in
that national clap for the NHS but it's
not just the NHS it's our police social
care workers teachers everybody who
works in schools our DWP staff an
amazing national effort by the public
services but also by every member of the
British public who's volunteering
incredible response 600,000 people have
volunteered to take part in a great
national effort to protect people from
the consequences of coronavirus I want
to thank you I will thank everybody
who's working to keep our country going
through this epidemic and we will get
through it and the way we're going to
get through it is of course by applying
the measures that you'll have heard so
much about and the more effectively we
all comply with those measures the
faster our country will come through
this epidemic and the faster we'll all
bounce back so thank you to everybody
who's doing what I'm doing working from
home to stop the spread of the virus
from household to household that's the
way we're going to win we're gonna beat
it we're gonna beat it together stay at
home protect the NHS and save lie
you